begin here this morning with the
Congressional January 6 committee
formally issuing a subpoena to former
president Donald Trump the panel sent a
letter to Trump on Friday requesting
that he hand over documents by November
4th and that he testify under oath on or
about November 14th after the midterm
elections it is unclear if Trump will
testify that subpoena could likely set
the stage for a long legal struggle on
Friday Trump's longtime Ally Steve
Bannon was sentenced to prison for
defying a subpoena from the January 6th
committee Scott McFarland reports
the January 6 committee demanded
testimony and documents from the former
president arguing he played a central
role in trying to subvert the election
and triggered the assault on the Capitol
in the letter accompanying The subpoena
they write the evidence demonstrates
that you knew this activity was illegal
and unconstitutional and also knew that
your assertions of fraud were false
panel member Pete Aguilar said they're
open to questioning Trump in a live
hearing we're going to be prepared if if
the former president decides to come and
if he puts restrictions on it for live
testimony and we're going to be prepared
for that eventuality we will be prepared
in any scenario to take testimony uh
under oath from the former president the
committee wants information about
Trump's dealings with key players who've
all pleaded the fifth plus all his
Communications by phone text or the
private messaging app signal on January
6th they also want any information
referring to the proud boys Oath Keepers
or other militia groups we are gated to
seek answers directly from the man who
set this all In Motion a source tells
CBS news that among the documents seized
on August 8 that Trump's Florida estate
Was Won containing information about
Iran's missile program and another
including highly sensitive intelligence
work aimed at China material that if
exposed could jeopardize foreign sources
or even prompt other countries to
retaliate against the U.S to the extent
his supporters are calling this a
overblown documentary matter we're
talking the crown jewels it's hard to
see how anybody could do greater damage
than spiriting them away and not keeping
them protected meanwhile Trump's former
top eight Steve Bannon was reprimanded
in federal court in Washington for
failing to comply with a January 6
committee subpoena judge Carl Nichols a
trump appointee ordered Bannon to serve
four months in prison and pay a sixty
five hundred dollar fine saying he
showed no remorse for his actions
Bannon ignored reporters questions only
attacking President Biden and we will
groom the Biden Administration ends on
the eighth evening of the 8th of
November the judge will allow Bannon to
remain free pending an appeal in his
case which could take months meanwhile a
trump attorney tells CBS News the
committee's decision to publicly
announce that subpoena was unprecedented
and inappropriate raising questions
about whether the former president ever
intends to cooperate for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Scott McFarland at the
Capitol